[Music]
when i got the call from dc comics to
write batman the ongoing series it was
super surreal i've wanted to write
batman my whole life you know it's
definitely been a very big dream of mine
you know i i have a batman tattoo you
know it's it's always been something i
wanted to do
and i've gotten the opportunity to work
on batman a few times i've actually
gotten it right on on this batman series
since rebirth it was just something that
was really important to me and so when i
i got that call i couldn't wait to get
started on working you know and i'm
immediately diving into it thinking
about the world like that night i i went
and i watched the first batman movie the
1989 one just to kind of remind myself
of something
of you know why i love batman uh so it's
very very surreal but at the same time i
was just so excited to get to work like
just to dive right in and get to writing
if you've been reading batman recently
or haven't been reading batman recently
it was important to me that both those
things were taken care of here that i
honored what james had been doing before
in the book for the last two years but
then i also wanted to make sure that you
hadn't been reading it you could just
jump right into it
you know part of the story is that we're
coming out of fear state which is a big
batman event
and afterwards you know gotham has gone
through a bit of a change they've all
kind of survived this scarecrow attack
and so the city is sort of changing and
batman sees that and because of the
events of fierce state batman is
actually leaving gotham for a bit and so
it gives us kind of a point of a news
story of a new case about maybe able to
leave gotham and you're able to pick it
up there so it allows you if you you're
coming into a new you get to have kind
of a new case and a new adventure
so keeping james's run in mind i think
one of the things that james really
brought to it was a lot of excitement
and he really brought a lot of new
things to it new characters new ideas
and new toys
and so i wanted to keep that running i
wanted to be able to still introduce new
characters like we're reducing his new
villain his name is this and we're gonna
go play with some new toys in the dcu
with batman but i also wanted to bring
bruce back into the main dc and start
having interact with different pieces of
dc we haven't seen in a while and then
for me you know one of the things with
james's run was it was and he just goes
back to james detective run too it's
like it's bruce plus a major supporting
cast the characters you had ghost maker
and punchline and harley and i want to
keep some of that running but i wanted
to get back into
bruce's head and and spend some time
with just batman and make sure
everything was through his point of view
and that was one of the ways i was going
to kind of depart from what he was doing
and take it on my my own spin was to
make it much more about just batman by
himself on this adventure
so with this new run like i said before
we're using this new villain uh their
name is abyss see for me it's always
been interesting of how batman uses the
darkness and shadows
to uh he uses them as a weapon against
people and so i started thinking what if
someone may figure out how to use that
against bruce
against batman and so that's where he
started developing abyss as a character
who also learns how to use the darkness
but also take the way batman uses it
learn from it and then turn it around
against him they were really fun
character and the way we're doing their
powers is stupid different so it's gonna
be really interesting and then jorge
molina who came in and got to do a new
design for this character and really
just kicked up with it
[Music]
with jorge he brings a kind of calm
horror and tension to it i've been a fan
of jorge's molinos for a long time i
actually recommended or a years ago
because jorge would do all these like
awesome pickups of batman online
and so i started like showing that work
to dc and being like this guy should do
batman something this guy should do
batman someday and sure enough the day
that they call me the batman they're
also like oh jorge's gonna do it so i'll
just kind of came together when i was
recommending him for that job it wasn't
for me it was i thought he would do a
really great job with that character
and sure enough i got lucky and he gets
a drop with me and so far like the
thoughtfulness that he puts into gotham
into the characters and to kind of this
energy of gotham and batman and he's
bringing so much to it
[Music]
you